This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Richard Davidson was a 22-year-old graduate student when he went to India to attend an intense meditation retreat. He quickly found the journey had a surprise in store for him. The bus that we were taking up into the Himalayas got stuck in a landslide, which was pretty scary actually. stuck in a landslide which was pretty scary actually. Richie and the other passengers found themselves pinned on the edge of a cliff. On one side was a mountain wall, on the other a sheer drop.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。理查德·戴维森22岁时是一名研究生，当时他去印度参加了一场高强度的冥修静修活动。他很快发现，这段旅程为他准备了一个惊喜。我们坐着去喜马拉雅山的巴士陷入了山体滑坡，实际上这挺吓人的。陷入了山体滑坡，实际上这挺吓人的。瑞奇和其他乘客发现自己被困在悬崖边上。一边是山壁，另一边是垂直的陡坡。
Rocks rained down around them and rain pounded against the bus window. They felt paralyzed. And then this unbelievable scene transpired where another bus pulled up from the other side and we exchanged. We literally took our belongings. We walked over this landslide into this other bus and this other bus on these single lane narrow roads that are literally four or five thousand feet drop, with no rail had to go backward for maybe a mile or two until it got to a place where it can turn around. That trip to India would eventually prompt Richie to see his own life as a bridge across a divided
岩石在他们周围如雨般落下，雨点猛烈地敲打着巴士车窗。他们感到动弹不得。接着，发生了这样一个难以置信的场景：另一辆巴士从对面开过来，我们进行了换乘。我们 literalmente（字面意思）拿着随身物品。我们走过这个山体滑坡处上了这辆大巴，而这辆大巴在单车道狭窄道路上——这些路旁边 literalmente（字面意思）就是四五千英尺的悬崖，还没有护栏——不得不倒车大约一英里或两英里，直到找到一个可以调头的地方。那趟印度之旅最终促使瑞奇将自己的人生视为一座连接分裂道路的桥梁。
road. One side of the road was represented by his teachers at Harvard and mainstream psychology. The other was represented by his meditation teachers in the United States and India, including eventually the Dalai Lama. Both the psychologists and the meditators were engaged with the life of the mind, but from different sides. The scientists wanted to study the brain from the outside in, using scans and monitors and probes. The meditator said,
路的这一边代表着他在哈佛的老师和主流心理学。另一边代表着他在美国和印度的冥修老师，最终包括达赖喇嘛。心理学家和冥修者都投身于心灵的生活，但来自不同的侧面。科学家们想从外到内地研究大脑，使用扫描仪、监视器和探针。冥修者说，
hang on, what we experienced during our contemplative practices cannot be captured by crude photos of the brain. How can a Polaroid camera capture the complexity of an ocean? As we explored in part one of the story, Richie soon discovered that both sets of practitioners viewed the other with deep suspicion. If you missed that episode, I recommend you go back and listen to it first. Today on the show, we examine how Richie Davidson eventually found a way
等等，我们在静修实践中所经历的，是无法用粗糙的大脑照片捕捉的。拍立得相机怎么能捕捉到大海的复杂性呢？正如我们在本集故事的第一部分中所探讨的，瑞奇很快发现，这两批实践者都以深深的怀疑看待对方。如果你错过了那一集，我建议你先回去听听。今天的节目中，我们来看看瑞奇·戴维森最终是如何找到一种方法的，
to synthesize two very different approaches to the mind. It would take courage and patience, like that dramatic mountain bust rescue. Bridging the divided road this week on Hidden Brain. In 1992, Richie Davidson and his colleagues carried 5,000 pounds of scientific equipment with them to India. With the blessings of the Dalai Lama, Richie was hoping to use a scientific instruments to capture what was happening in the minds of highly experienced Tibetan meditators in remote mountain retreats. Over the course of three weeks, literally zero of the practitioners agreed to allow us to
来综合对心灵的这两种截然不同的方法。这需要勇气和耐心，就像那场戏剧性的山地巴士大救援一样。本周《隐藏的大脑》将弥合这条分裂的道路。1992年，瑞奇·戴维森和他的同事们带着5000磅重的科学设备来到了印度。在达赖喇嘛的祝福下，瑞奇希望利用科学仪器捕捉偏远山区静修中经验丰富的西藏冥修者心灵中发生的事情。在三周的时间里， literally（字面意思）没有任何一个实践者同意让我们把
put electrodes on their head. They had this view that somehow if we put electrodes on their head, it's going to put something into their head. And we explain to them that the electrodes don't transmit electricity. They simply pick up electricity. Nevertheless, they were skeptical and they didn't want to participate. It was a complete bust, total and complete bust. Richie and esteemed regrouped, dejected, but they had one further humiliation in store for them. In the last couple of days, the Dalai Lama said, you have all this equipment and you know,
电极放在他们的头上。他们有一种看法，不知何故，如果我们把电极放在他们的头上，就会把什么东西放进他们的脑袋里。我们向他们解释说，电极不传输电流。它们只是收集电流。然而，他们持怀疑态度，不想参与。这是一次彻底的失败，完全且彻底的失败。瑞奇和受人尊敬的团队重新集结，虽然沮丧，但还有一次羞辱在等着他们。在最后几天里，达赖喇嘛说，你们有这些设备，而且你知道，
you're here to do this research, and he you know the young monks will be interested in what you're doing and he asked if we please give a lecture and we said of course happy to give the lecture and so what we decided to do is since we didn't get to use the equipment to test these long-term practitioners we're gonna do a demonstration with the equipment for these young monks. Rather than ask one of the monks to serve as a volunteer, one of the researchers, neurobiologist Francisco Varela, step forward to be the guinea pig.
你们来到这里是为了做这项研究，他，你知道的，年轻的僧侣们会对你们在做的事情感兴趣，他问我们是否能做一个演讲，我们说当然很高兴能做这个演讲，所以我们决定的是，既然我们没有机会使用设备来测试这些长期实践者，我们要用这些设备为这些年轻的僧侣做一个演示。与其让其中一位僧侣作为志愿者，研究人员之一、神经生物学家弗朗西斯科·瓦雷拉站出来当了小白鼠。
So the way it worked is that I put the electrodes on Francisco's head, and then we were going to show all of these young monks what brain activity looked like on a computer monitor. Richie told the monks that he would show them the inner workings of the brain by measuring Francisco's brain electrical activity. Specifically, the scientists told the monks they could demonstrate what compassion looked like when you measured it scientifically. Compassion of course is a core interest of Buddhist
所以它的运作方式是，我把电极戴在弗朗西斯科的头上，然后我们将在电脑显示器上向所有这些年轻的僧侣展示大脑活动是什么样子的。瑞奇告诉僧侣们，他将通过测量弗朗西斯科的大脑电活动来展示大脑的内部运作。具体来说，科学家们告诉僧侣们，他们可以证明当你科学地测量时，同情心是什么样子的。同情心当然是佛教实践的核心兴趣。
practice. The scientists figured that they could teach the monks a thing or two about the neural signature of compassion. So there were about 200 monks who were sitting on cushions on the floor, very dutifully sitting, and we were futsing with the electrodes. And it took a while. Those were the older days where it took like 45 minutes to get it all set up and to have the EEG activity, the brain electrical activity nicely displayed on the computer monitor. Finally, we were ready. And we sort of parted and so they can now see Francisco clearly with this electrode cap on his head. And the 200 monks just burst out laughing. They were hysterically
科学家们认为，他们可以教给僧侣们一些关于同情心神经特征的知识。所以大约有200名僧侣坐在地上的垫子上，非常恭顺地坐着，而我们则在摆弄电极。这花了一段时间。那是过去的年代，设置好这一切并让脑电图活动、大脑电活动很好地显示在电脑显示器上大约需要45分钟。最后，我们准备好了。我们稍微让开，这样他们现在可以清楚地看到弗朗西斯科头上戴着这个电极帽。这200名僧侣突然哄堂大笑。他们笑得歇斯底里。
laughing. And we thought that they were laughing because, you know, Francisco looked kind of funny with the electrode cap on his head. And it turned out that we didn't realize this at the time, but it was pointed out to us the next day that that's not what they were laughing about. They were laughing at the fact that we were talking about studying compassion and we're putting electrodes on the head and not on the heart. That's what they were laughing about. The neuroscientists thought it was obvious that anything related to behavior had to be entirely shaped by the brain. The monks were equally confident. The scientists didn't know what they were talking about.
而我们以为他们在笑是因为，你知道的，弗朗西斯科头上戴着电极帽看起来有点搞笑。事实证明，我们当时并没有意识到这一点，但第二天有人向我们指出，他们笑的不是这个。他们笑的是，我们在谈论研究同情心，而我们把电极戴在头上而不是心上。这就是他们在笑的原因。神经科学家认为，任何与行为相关的事情都必须完全由大脑塑造，这是显而易见的。僧侣们同样确信。科学家们根本不知道自己在说什么。
On their way out of India, Ritchie asked the Dalai Lama for advice. The trip had been a failure from start to finish. The scientists and the monks were starting with different assumptions and they came from entirely different cultures. And he said, well, what you need to do then is to study practitioners who have been teaching in the West. When Ritchie got home to Wisconsin, he followed the Dalai Lama's advice.
在离开印度的路上，瑞奇向达赖喇嘛征求建议。这次旅行从头到尾都是一次失败。科学家和僧侣以不同的假设开始，他们来自完全不同的文化。他说，好吧，那你需要做的是去研究那些一直在西方教学的实践者。瑞奇回到威斯康星州的家中后，听从了达赖喇嘛的建议。
He recruited meditation practitioners who had familiarity with the United States to come into his lab. They were mostly people who were teaching in the West, but all of them had really deep meditation experience. All of them, one of the requirements for the study is that they have completed at least one three-year retreat and doing at least eight hours of practice every day for three years. Richie recorded that brain electrical activity and he observed something
他招募了熟悉美国的冥修实践者来到他的实验室。他们大多是在西方教学的人，但所有人都有非常深厚的冥修经验。所有人，研究的要求之一是他们至少完成了一次为期三年的静修，并且在三年里每天至少进行八小时的练习。瑞奇记录了他们的大脑电活动，并观察到了一些不同寻常的现象。
unusual. We observed these very high amplitude gamma oscillations. Gamma is a very fast frequency of brain electrical activity. It's a frequency of about 40 cycles per second. You and I have gamma activity. Everybody has gamma activity, but it's typically seen for really short periods of time in most of us. And it's seen during moments of insight. And so, for example, if you've been working on a problem and suddenly something comes to you, during that sort of quarter of a second where you just have this flash, we often see this kind of gamma activity.
我们观察到了这些非常高振幅的伽马振荡。伽马是一种非常快速的大脑电活动频率。它大约是每秒40个周期的频率。你和我都有伽马活动。每个人都有伽马活动，但在我们大多数人身上，它通常只在很短的时间内出现。它出现在顿悟的时刻。所以，例如，如果你一直在处理一个问题，突然有什么东西涌上心头，在大约四分之一秒的闪念中，我们经常会看到这种伽马活动。
Gamma activity is also seen at the moment where different elements of a percept come together. So, for example, imagine biting into a juicy apple. When you imagine that there are different elements that you can, that often occur to most people, you can imagine the tactile sensation of your teeth digging into a crisp apple. You can imagine the juice sort of being released and the taste. You can imagine the color of the apple. You can hear the sound of the apple. You can hear the sound of the crunch. So all of these different elements come together in a single unified percept. It turns out that gamma
伽马活动也会在知觉的不同元素汇聚在一起的那一刻出现。例如，想象咬一口多汁的苹果。当你想象时，会有你可以体验到的不同元素，这些元素经常会出现在大多数人身上，你可以想象牙齿咬入清脆苹果的触觉。你可以想象果汁被释放出来的感觉和味道。你可以想象苹果的颜色。你可以听到苹果的声音。你可以听到清脆的咀嚼声。所有这些不同的元素汇聚成一个单一的、统一的知觉。事实证明，在头脑不同部分同步的伽马
activity that is synchronized in different parts of the brain is the core mechanism that binds those different elements together to create a unified percept in our experience. So they had long durations of gamma activity and it wasn't just when they were meditating, but it was also during their baseline state. Long-term practitioners of meditation often report heightened states of perception and awareness. The report seeing connections that most of us might miss. That twig on the tree isn't just a twig. It's also a leaf, a fruit, and a new branch, just in embryonic form.
活动是将这些不同元素绑定在一起的核心机制，从而在我们的体验中创造出一个统一的知觉。因此，他们拥有长时间的伽马活动，而且不仅在他们冥修时，在他们的基线状态下也是如此。长期冥修的实践者经常报告说，他们的知觉和觉察状态得到了提升。他们报告说看到了我们大多数人可能会错过的联系。树上的那一根细枝不仅仅是一根细枝。它也是一片叶子、一个果实和一个新枝条，只是处于胚胎形态。
Change in the Buddhist tradition is the only constant. Meditators say they often have a deep appreciation of the nature of change, including changes that transform the worlds of life into the worlds of death and regeneration. The Gama-Bers Ritchie saw offered a clue to what might be happening in the minds of master meditators. The amazing thing about this was that unlike most other signals in brain electrical activity, this was visually apparent to the naked eye. Most of the time when we do this kind of research, we have to process these signals with fancy computer algorithms. And, you know, after months of processing, we get a finding, which is a statistical finding. Here, it was visually apparent. And it was so apparent that we thought it was an artifact at first.
在佛教传统中，变化是唯一的常数。冥修者说，他们对变化的本质有着深刻的理解，包括将生命世界转变为死亡和再生世界的变化。瑞奇看到的“伽马狂欢”为大师级冥修者的心灵中可能发生的事情提供了一条线索。这件了不起的事情是，与大脑电活动中的大多数其他信号不同，这是肉眼可见的。大多数时候，当我们做这种研究时，我们必须用奇特的计算机算法来处理这些信号。而且，你知道，经过几个月的处理，我们得到了一个发现，这是一个统计学上的发现。在这里，它是肉眼可见的。而且它是如此明显，以至于我们起初以为它是一个伪影。
We thought it was something, you know, wrong. We thought it was muscle artifact. We were convinced it couldn't be real because it was so, so large and so prominent. And we had to do a whole year of various kinds of control experiments to convince ourselves that this was indeed real. The finding was nothing short of remarkable. Richie found that meditation, at least in some circumstances, by some practitioners, could lead to structural changes in the brain.
我们以为有什么东西，你知道的，出错了。我们以为那是肌肉伪影。我们确信它不可能是真的，因为它是如此之大、如此显眼。我们不得不进行整整一年的各种对照实验，才让自己相信这确实是真的。这一发现简直非同寻常。瑞奇发现，冥修，至少在某些情况下，由某些实践者进行，可以导致大脑的结构性变化。
It could literally change our minds. The paper received a lot of attention, both in the public and within academia. It led to a windfall of interest in the science of meditation. But when this paper came out in 2004, it was a real inflection point because it was the first time that a paper on meditation had ever been published in this August scientific journal. And if you look at the publication rate of papers, scientific papers on meditation, you will see an inflection point at around 2005, where it just begins to steeply rise, and I would like to think in part, it was stimulated by the work that was
它真的可以改变我们的思想。这篇论文在公众和学术界都受到了广泛关注。它引发了人们对冥修科学的巨大兴趣。但当这篇论文在2004年发表时，它是一个真正的转折点，因为这是关于冥修的论文第一次发表在如此权威的科学期刊上。如果你看一下论文的发表率，关于冥修的科学论文，你会发现在2005年左右有一个转折点，它开始急剧上升，我想部分原因是由这篇论文中代表的工作所刺激的。
represented in this paper. When we come back, Richie runs an unusual study where he subjects experienced meditators to intense bursts of pain. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Through much of his career, psychologist Richie Davidson has wanted to bridge two approaches to understanding the mind. The first he learned while getting his PhD in psychology at Harvard.
当我们回来时，瑞奇进行了一项不同寻常的研究，他让经验丰富的冥修者承受强烈突发的疼痛。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。在其职业生涯的大部分时间里，心理学家瑞奇·戴维森一直想弥合理解心灵的两种方法。第一种是他在哈佛攻读心理学博士学位时学到的。
This approach examined the brain from the outside, using tools like electrodes and brain scanners. The other approach came from meditation retreats that Richie attended and involved deep introspection and observation. During the first of those retreats, Richie found himself in agonizing pain, as he sat still for hour upon hour of meditation. But when the pain became nearly unbearable, Richie decided to turn to word it instead of trying to avoid it. He studied the pain, tried to tease apart its sensations. Instead of responding to the pain, he observed it. You know, I remember very distinctly having the experience this first time
这种方法从外部检查大脑，使用电极和脑部扫描仪等工具。另一种方法来自瑞奇参加的冥修静修，涉及深刻的内省和观察。在其中第一次静修期间，瑞奇发现自己陷入了极度痛苦之中，因为他一小时又一小时地静坐冥修。但当疼痛变得几乎难以忍受时，瑞奇决定转向疼痛，而不是试图避开它。他研究疼痛，试图剖析它的感觉。他没有对疼痛做出反应，而是观察它。你知道，我非常清楚地记得第一次经历那种经历，
of having the pain be completely transformed where I was experiencing it as tingling, as heat, as different kinds of sensations. And when you really penetrate it, you can see all of these very qualities and it's not just one thing. You know, we label it as pain, but that's a label. And that the actual experience is far more granular and differentiated. Back home in the United States, Richie decided to run a study where he measured the effects of pain on the brains of long-term meditators and non-meditators. The way I often talk about this is many listeners recognize that when they go, for example, to
疼痛发生了彻底的转变，我把它体验为刺痛、作为热感、作为不同种类的感觉。当你真正穿透它时，你可以看到所有这些非常细腻的特质，它不只是一件事。你知道，我们把它贴上疼痛的标签，但那只是一个标签。实际的体验要颗粒化和差异化得多。回到美国的家中后，瑞奇决定进行一项研究，测量疼痛对长期冥修者和非冥修者大脑的影响。我经常这样谈论这件事：许多听众认识到，当他们去，例如，
a cardiologist to get their heart examined, the cardiologist would often have you do a cardiac stress test where you would exercise on an exercise bike or treadmill and exercise the heart to evaluate its function. And what we are doing in some sense is a stress test for the mind and the brain. One of the ways we can do that is with physical pain. We use pain that is extremely real. We use heat as a painful stimulus and we can deliver heat in a very, very safe and very controlled way where we can very precisely regulate the degree of heat and it's a plate that goes on the owner area of the wrist, it's a very sensitive area and we have water that circulates through this plate very rapidly and we can precisely control the temperature of the water.
心脏病专家那里检查心脏时，心脏病专家通常会让你做一个心脏压力测试，让你在健身车或跑步机上锻炼，锻炼心脏以评估其功能。从某种意义上说，我们正在做的是针对心灵和大闹的压力测试。我们可以做到这一点的方法之一是通过身体疼痛。我们使用非常真实的疼痛。我们使用热作为痛苦的刺激，我们可以以非常、非常安全和非常受控的方式传递热量，我们可以非常精确地调节热量程度，这是一个放在手腕尺骨部位的平板，这是一个非常敏感的区域，我们有水通过这个平板快速循环，我们可以精确控制水温。
We give them one experience of this pain and I've had this done to myself many times and I can tell you it is really, really painful, and it feels like your skin is burning. And you can sort of tolerate it for one or two seconds, but then after two seconds or three seconds, you really feel it's unbearable. And we have this device strapped on so you can't just simply pull your hand away. So we give them this experience and then we bring them into the MRI scanner. We
我们让他们体验一次这种疼痛，我自己也经历过很多次，我可以告诉你，这真的是非常、非常痛，感觉就像你的皮肤在燃烧。你可以忍受一两秒钟，但在两三秒钟之后，你真的会觉得它无法忍受。我们把这个设备绑在上面，所以你不能简单地把手抽回来。所以我们让他们体验这个，然后把他们带进核磁共振扫描仪。我们
tell them that when they hear a tone, when they hear beep, it means 10 seconds later, they're going to get zapped with this pain. The pain lasts for 10 seconds and after those 10 seconds, there is another 10 second period which we call a recovery period where nothing happens and we can just look to see how the brain responds subsides. And one of the things that we know is where the networks in the brain are that process this kind of physical pain. This is known in the scientific literature as the pain matrix. It's a well-defined set of brain regions, so we know exactly where to look. So again, the volunteers, both meditators and non-meditators, are given an experience of excruciating pain. They're then told that when a beep goes off, they will get zapped again in 10 seconds. The brains of the non-meditators respond immediately. The areas in the brain that are part of this pain matrix begin to activate immediately.
告诉他们，当他们听到一个音调，当他们听到“哔”的一声时，意味着10秒后，他们将受到这种疼痛的电击。疼痛持续10秒钟，在那10秒钟之后，还有另一个10秒钟的时期，我们称之为恢复期，什么都不会发生，我们可以观察大脑的反应如何消退。我们知道的一件事是处理这种身体疼痛的大脑网络在哪里。这在科学文献中被称为疼痛矩阵。这是一组定义明确的大脑区域，所以我们确切地知道在哪里寻找。再次强调，志愿者（包括冥修者和非冥修者）都体验了剧烈的疼痛。然后他们被告知，当蜂鸣声响起时，他们将在10秒后再次受到电击。非冥修者的大脑立即作出反应。大脑中属于这个疼痛矩阵的区域开始立即被激活。
Nothing has happened other than the tone. They haven't received any painful stimulus, and just presenting the tone was sufficient to activate most of the pain matrix. When the actual physical pain started, the pain matrix continued to pain. After that, and then they had a very slow recovery over the next 10 seconds. The advanced meditators come in and when the tone occurs, there is no significant activation in any area of the pain matrix. None, flat, zero, nothing.
除了那个音调之外什么都没发生。他们没有收到任何痛苦的刺激，仅仅是呈现音调就足以激活大部分疼痛矩阵。当实际的身体疼痛开始时，疼痛矩阵继续疼痛。在那之后，他们在接下来的10秒钟内恢复得非常缓慢。高级冥修者进来了，当音调出现时，疼痛矩阵的任何区域都没有明显的激活。没有，平坦的，零，什么都没有。
So there's absolutely no change in any area of the pain matrix when they hear this anticipatory tone. Then when the pain comes on, they actually show a huge response. And in certain areas of the brain, it's actually a larger response, significantly larger than in the controls. Particularly the areas that are sensitive to the sensory qualities of the pain. And then when the pain goes off, after the ten seconds, they come right back down to baseline. And this is, we believe, the neural signature of resilience. And it is paralleled in their reports of pain.
因此，当他们听到这个预期的音调时，疼痛矩阵的任何区域绝对没有任何变化。然后当疼痛出现时，他们实际上表现出巨大的反应。在某些大脑区域，它实际上是一个更大的反应，明显比对照组更大。特别是对疼痛的感觉特质敏感的区域。然后当疼痛在10秒后消失时，他们立即回到基线。我们相信，这就是韧性的神经特征，并且与他们对疼痛的报告相平行。
So they report that the painful stimulus is very intense and actually the intensity ratings that they give it are no different than the intensity ratings that are given by the controls, but they rate it as dramatically less distressing. So, what is this telling you? What is the fact that they're not showing a reaction in the pain matrix when you play the tone? What do you think that's telling us at a conceptual level here, Richie? I think it's telling us in part that they're living in the moment, so to speak.
因此，他们报告说痛苦的刺激非常强烈，实际上他们给出的强度评分与对照组给出的强度评分没有区别，但他们认为痛苦程度显着降低。那么，这说明了什么？当您播放音调时，他们没有在疼痛矩阵中表现出反应这一事实说明了什么？瑞奇，你认为这在概念层面上说明了什么？我认为这在某种程度上说明他们活在当下，可以说是这样。
They're not worrying before they need to. There's a big chunk of real estate that we have in the front of our brain called the prefrontal cortex. And it's larger in humans in relation to the rest of the brain mass than in any other species. And it is responsible for many of the things that are characteristically human. And one of the things that is characteristically human is our ability to do what psychologists have called mental time travel.
他们在不需要的时候不会提前担忧。我们大脑前部有一大块房地产，叫做前额叶皮层。与其他任何物种相比，它在人类中相对于其他大脑质量而言更大。它负责许多人类特有的事情。人类特有的事情之一就是我们做心理学家所称的心智时间旅行的能力。
We can anticipate the future and we can reflect on the past in ways that far exceed what any other species can do. This is obviously extremely important for all of the amazing things that humans can do and for their adaptability, but it also is what gets us into trouble. And it gets us into trouble because we're worrying about the future and ruminating about the past so much of the time. Think about the last time you suffered an injury or felt sick. If you're like most people, the suffering caused by the injury or the illness
我们可以预测未来，我们可以反思过去，其方式远远超过任何其他物种所能做到的。这显然对于人类可以做的所有惊人事情以及他们的适应能力极其重要，但这也是让我们陷入麻烦的原因。它让我们陷入麻烦，因为我们大部分时间都在担心未来和反思过去。想想你最近一次遭受伤害或生病的时候。如果你像大多数人一样，伤害或疾病带来的痛苦
was compounded by your thoughts. Maybe you asked yourself why the illness had to happen to you. Maybe you replayed the injury and berated yourself for getting in harm's way. Maybe you fantasized about what it would feel like to be healthy again, only to find yourself returning to the despair of your suffering. And so what this experiment shows is that meditation training can really help us to be more in the present. So when this tone comes on that signifies that a pain is about to occur, what happens
被你的想法复合了。也许你问自己为什么这场疾病非要降临在你身上。也许你重播了受伤过程并责备自己陷入险境。也许你幻想再次恢复健康会是什么感觉，结果发现自己回到了痛苦的绝望中。所以这个实验表明，冥修训练真的可以帮助我们更多地处于当下。所以当这个标志着疼痛即将发生的音调响起时，会发生什么
in the brain of these meditators is that the auditory part of their brain registers the tone. And that's it. And then when the pain comes on, it's registers the tone, and that's it. And then when the pain comes on, it's not like they're blocking out the pain. They're not blocking it out at all. In fact, their sensory channels are even more open. But then when the pain goes off, they recover very quickly. And again, it's being able to turn off the prefrontal cortex when it's no longer necessary, and
在这些冥修者的大脑中，他们大脑的听觉部分记录了音调。就是这样。然后当疼痛来临时，它记录了音调，就是这样。然后当疼痛来临时，并不是他们在阻挡疼痛。他们根本没有阻挡。事实上，他们的感官通道更加开放。但当疼痛消失时，他们恢复得非常快。同样，能够在不再必要时关闭前额叶皮层，并且
they don't ruminate about what just happened. So this is something that I think is very instructive for how these practices can change our everyday behavior. What Richie is talking about here is a core tenet of many spiritual and psychotherapeutic techniques, suffering may be inevitable in our lives. By the way we respond to suffering is not inevitable. With practice we can spend less time ruminating about the past or fantasizing about the future and more time fully experiencing the here and now.
他们不会对刚刚发生的事情进行反思。所以我认为这对于这些实践如何改变我们的日常行为非常有启发性。瑞奇在这里谈论的是许多精神和心理治疗技术的核心信条，痛苦在我们的生活中可能是不可避免的。顺便说一句，我们对痛苦的反应并不是不可避免的。通过练习，我们可以减少对过去的反思或对未来的幻想，花更多的时间完全体验此时此地。
In another study, Richie examined the effects of contemplative practices on the immune system. What we did in this study is we used employees of a high-tech corporation who reported a lot of stress. We randomly assigned them to a condition where they went through mindfulness-based stress reduction. Another group was a control condition, and we gave everyone a flu shot. What we did was simply that we took blood samples before and after the flu shot, which allowed us to quantitatively determine the efficacy of the flu vaccine for each individual. That is, we can look at the antibody titers that are mounted in response to the vaccine, which provides a hard-nosed objective indicator of how effective the vaccine is.
在另一项研究中，瑞奇检查了静修实践对免疫系统的影响。我们在本研究中所做的是使用了报告有很大压力的高科技公司的员工。我们将他们随机分到接受基于正念的减压的条件中。另一组是对照条件，我们给每个人注射了流感疫苗。我们所做的很简单，就是在流感疫苗注射前后抽取血样，这使我们能够定量确定流感疫苗对每个个体2的效力。也就是说，我们可以查看响应疫苗而产生的抗体滴度，这为疫苗的有效性提供了坚硬客观的指标。
And the data were really clear in showing that their indeed was a significant effect such that the individuals who went through the meditation condition had a significantly more robust response to the flu vaccine compared to their controlled counterparts. Why do you think this would happen? Why would meditation affect the immune system, Richard? Well, first of all, the most honest answer is we don't fully know at this point in time. It is a topic of active investigation, but we have some clues. We know that the immune system is very influenced by stress neurobiology. We know that some of the hormones, for example, that are released during stress will directly
数据非常清楚地表明，确实存在显着的效果，与对照组相比，经历冥修条件的人对流感疫苗产生了明显更强健的反应。你认为为什么会这样？理查德，为什么冥修会影响免疫系统？好吧，首先，最诚实的回答是我们目前还不是完全知道。这是一个正在积极研究的主题，但我们有一些线索。我们知道免疫系统受压力神经生物学的影响很大。我们知道，例如，在压力期间释放的一些激素会直接
impede with an immune response. If you engage in a strategy that decreases your stress response, it can have an effect on immunity. Richie is also discovered that our tendency to focus on ourselves is dampened after meditation. Other researchers found that regular meditators show less anger than a control group. Some of Richie's most interesting research
阻碍免疫反应。如果你参与减少压力反应的策略，它会对免疫力产生影响。瑞奇还发现，我们在冥修后对自己的关注倾向减弱了。其他研究人员发现，经常冥修的人表现出的愤怒比对照组少。瑞奇最有趣的一些研究
has explored something he noticed when he first became entranced by meditation. The friends who introduced him to meditation seemed to be among the kindest, most compassionate people he'd met. Was there meditation, an engine for their kindness? This was a difficult question to study scientifically. But in one experiment, Richie gave volunteers $50. One group underwent training in compassion-based mindfulness techniques.
探索了他第一次被冥修迷住时注意到的事情。向他介绍冥修的朋友似乎是他遇到的最善良、最有同情心的人之一。他们的冥修是他们善良的引擎吗？这是一个很难进行科学研究的问题。但在一个实验中，瑞奇给了志愿者50美元。一组接受了基于同情心的正念技术的培训。
Another group did not. Then, all of the subjects observed a financial transaction between two strangers. It's an unfair transaction where funds are being distributed highly inequitably between two people. So one person is going to make out with a lot of money, and a second person is going to get very little. Notice that the volunteer doesn't have to get involved. This is a transaction between two strangers. The volunteer could easily tell herself, I've got my $50, I'm all set.
另一组没有。然后，所有受试者都观察了两个陌生人之间的金融交易。这是一笔不公平的交易，资金在两个人之间分配得非常不均。所以一个人会赚大钱，而第二个人会得到很少。请注意，志愿者不必参与其中。这是两个陌生人之间的交易。志愿者很容易告诉自己，我有我的50美元，我全都搞定了。
Who cares if some stranger is a victim in an unfair transaction? And they're given the choice. We then tell them as part of the experiment that they can render a transaction between two people who are strangers to them to be more fair if they use their own money that we just gave them. If they use some of the $50 that we just gave them to make that transaction to be more fair and more altruistic. And we ask whether training and compassion leads people to be more monetarily altruistic in this circumstance. We've done this with people who are just learning to meditate, who've just done a few weeks of compassion
谁在乎某个陌生人是否是不公平交易中的受害人？他们得到了选择。然后我们作为实验的一部分告诉他们，如果他们使用我们刚刚给他们的自己的钱，他们可以使他们不认识的两个人之间的交易变得更公平。如果他们使用我们刚刚给他们的一部分50美元来使交易变得更公平、更利他。我们询问同情心培训是否会导致人们在这种情况下在金钱上更加利他。我们对刚开始学习冥修的人、刚做了几周同情心
meditation training. And what we find is that they indeed behave more altruistically than their randomly assigned counterparts who received another kind of training that did not entail any compassion. Another example in a very different age group is work that we've done with young children because we've been interested in how we can train these qualities starting in kids who are in preschool who are four and five years of age.
冥修训练的人进行了这项研究。我们发现，他们确实比随机分配的、接受了不包含任何同情心的其他类型训练的对照组表现得更利他。另一个针对不同年龄组的例子是我们对幼儿所做的工作，因为我们一直对如何从四五岁还在上学前班的孩子开始培养这些品质感兴趣。
So what is a currency that is valued by a four-year-old? Well, kids love stickers. And we did a very simple experiment. What we did is we found out through various kinds of ratings who the child's best friend was in the class, who the child's least favorite person was in the class, and then we had a child that they had never seen before, and a fourth category was a obviously sick looking child who was in bed with a bandage on his head, and we had pictures of each of these kids.
那么，四岁小孩看重的货币是什么？好吧，孩子们喜欢贴纸。我们做了一个非常简单的实验。我们所做的是通过各种评分发现孩子在班上最好的朋友是谁，孩子最不喜欢的人是谁，然后我们有一个他们从未见过的孩子，第四个类别是一个看起来明显生病的孩子，他躺在床上，头上缠着绷带，我们有每个孩子的照片。
And what we did is we put these pictures on envelopes, and we also had one envelope, which had their own picture on it. And we told the kids, here are 20 stickers. You can keep all the stickers for yourself, and if you wanna keep them all for yourself, put them in the envelope with your picture on it. But if you wanna give some to other people,
我们所做的是把这些照片贴在信封上，我们还有一个信封，上面有他们自己的照片。我们告诉孩子们，这里有20张贴纸。你可以把所有的贴纸留给自己，如果你想把它们都留给自己，把它们放进印有你照片的信封里。但如果你想把一些分给其他人，
you can do that too. And please distribute the stickers according to which kids you want to have these stickers. Now, teachers and parents routinely preach the importance of sharing and generosity to their children. Richie went a step further. In the work that we do with children, we do simple forms of contemplative training where
你也可以这样做。请根据你希望哪些孩子拥有这些贴纸来分发贴纸。现在，老师和家长通常会向孩子宣讲分享和慷慨的重要性。瑞奇更进一步。在我们与儿童合作的工作中，我们进行了简单的正念训练形式，其中
children are asked when thinking about a peer in their class to bring them into their mind and think about the fact that they are the same in many ways as they are in wanting to be happy and not have pain or suffering. I mean obviously in age-appropriate language. And we do these really short practices with these kids, you know, typically one or two minutes of practice. We find that the kids behave significantly more altruistically on this task. They give more stickers to others and particularly more stickers to their least favorite person and to the sick child and to the kid that they've never seen before compared to their randomly assigned counterparts who do not receive this training. I'm wondering if you might be able to tell me about some of the studies you've conducted, where you have not found an effect, where you may be you found a negative effect, and some of the studies you've conducted where you have not found an effect, where you or maybe you've found a negative effect, and some of the critiques that have been raised
当孩子们想到班上的同伴时，要求他们把他们带入脑海，并考虑到他们在渴望幸福、没有痛苦或苦难方面与他们有许多相同之处。我的意思是，显然是用适合年龄的语言。我们和这些孩子们做这些非常短暂的练习，你知道，通常是一两分钟的练习。我们发现，孩子们在这项任务上的利他行为明显更多。与其他随机分配但没有接受此训练的对照组相比，他们给其他人更多的贴纸，特别是给他们最不喜欢的人、生病的孩子以及从未见过的孩子更多的贴纸。我想知道您是否能告诉我一些您进行的研究，在这些研究中您没有发现效果，或者您可能发现了负面效果，以及一些您进行的研究中您没有发现效果，或者您可能发现了负面效果，以及对您的工作以及试图证明正念实践益处的更大工作提出的一些批评。因为再次回到你哈佛教授提出的担忧，你是一个实践者，你是一个信仰者，你是一个狂热者，你同时也是科学家，当制药公司对他们的药物进行试验时，我们有一个监管机构来评估这些研究的质量，因为我们了解存在利益冲突。现在，我不确定这里是否存在财务利益冲突。也许有，也许没有，但他们这里肯定存在情感利益冲突。科学有没有在基本上没有按照你认为的方式运作的地方？有没有研究未能成功实现？
about your work, and about the larger work of basically trying to prove the benefits of contemplative practices. Because again, going back to the concerns that your professors at Harvard were raising, you're a practitioner, you're a believer, you're an enthusiast, you're also the scientist, when pharmaceutical companies conduct trials of their drugs, we have a regulatory organization that evaluates the quality of those studies because we understand that there is a conflict of interest. Now, I'm not sure there's a financial conflict of interest here. Maybe there is, maybe there isn't, but they certainly an emotional conflict of interest here. Are there ways in which the science has basically not worked out the way you think? Are there studies that have failed to pan out?
是的，所以这些是非常棒、超级重要的问题，我非常感谢你提出这些问题，特别是你提出这些问题的方式，让我说几件事。首先，为了澄清，你知道，我们有一个我创建的名为“健康心灵创新”的非营利实体。我应该说这是一个非营利公司。我从未从这个“健康心灵创新”组织拿过一分钱，将来也不会从他们那里拿一分钱。事实上，我已经承诺捐出我所有的演讲和咨询费
Yeah, so those are really great, super important questions and I really appreciate you raising them and particularly the way you've raised them and let me just say a few things. First, to just clarify, you know, we have a nonprofit entity that I created called Healthy Minds Innovations. I should say that it is a nonprofit corporation. I have never been paid a penny by this Healthy Minds Innovations organization nor will I ever be paid a penny by them. And in fact, I've made a commitment to donate all of my speaking and consulting fees
在我活跃职业生涯的剩余时间里，直接流向这个非营利组织。所以没有财务利益冲突。但正如你正确地指出的那样，从某种意义上说，存在情感利益冲突，这是一个合理的问题。让我分享一个值得分享的故事。我是帮助邀请达赖喇嘛在神经科学学会会议上发言的环头目之一，这是世界主流、注重实证的神经科学家的最大集会，我认为这发生在2005年或6年前后。
for the remainder of my active career directly go to this nonprofit. So there is no financial conflict of interest. But as you do correctly and rightly point out, there is in some sense an emotional conflict of interest, which is a legitimate question. And let me just share a story, which is worth sharing. I was one of the ring leaders that helped to invite the Dalai Lama to speak at the Society for Neuroscience meeting, which is the world's largest convening of sort of mainstream, hard-knows neuroscientists, I think this occurred in maybe 2005 or six around then.
如果你回到这个时候，你会发现《纽约时报》头版有一篇关于这的文章，因为作为神经科学学会成员的科学家发起了一项请愿书，抗议达赖喇嘛出席这次会议，因为他们说一个宗教人物没有资格在科学会议上发表演讲。所以，但在《纽约时报》头版的这篇文章中，它也提到了我们的工作
And if you go back to this time, you will see that there was actually a front page New York Times article about this because there was a petition by scientists who are members of the Society for Neuroscientists protesting the Dalai Lama's appearance at this meeting because they said that a religious figure has no business giving a talk at a scientific meeting. So, but in this article on the New York Times on the front page it also mentioned our work
并点名我，说：“戴维森公开承认他自己冥修。”那么当涉及到这一点时，他怎么可能是一个客观的科学家呢？好吧，让我问一个研究身体锻炼对心脏的影响并且自己也进行身体锻炼的心脏病专家，对他们也可能会这么说，他们进行身体锻炼合适吗？一个研究知觉的科学家呢？他们应该停止感知吗？在某些方面，这很荒谬，但我从中获得了很多乐趣。但尽管如此，你的问题中确实有一些真实的东西，我认为这很重要。那么我们如何解决这个问题呢？好吧，我们发表了一整系列的文章
and singled me out and said, Davidson has admitted in public that he himself meditates. And so how could he possibly be an objective scientist when it comes to this? Well, let me ask a cardiologist who studies the effects of physical exercise on the heart and does physical exercise him or herself, same might be said of them, is it appropriate for them to ever do physical exercise? What about a scientist who studies perception? Should they stop perceiving? In certain ways, it was ridiculous, but I had a lot of fun with it. But nevertheless, there's something real in your question, which I do think is important. So how do we address this? Well, we have published a whole series of articles that are
非发现，这些发现没有复制文献中的发现，或者与我们认为冥修会在某种程度上产生益处但事实并非如此的假设相矛盾。我们一直非常严谨，并且坚定不移地致力于发表我们所有的非老发现。老实说，这些是我作为一名科学家真正感到自豪的最重要的科学论文之一。在瑞奇最初的论文于2004年发表后，一股关于正念的研究浪潮支持了它的益处。但在过去几年里，其他研究人员站出来对许多发现提出了质疑。
non-findings that don't replicate findings in literature or that are contradicting a hypothesis that we had where we thought that meditation would produce benefit in some way and it didn't. And we have been really rigorous and tenaciously committed to publishing all of our non-findings. And those are honestly some of the most important scientific papers of which I'm really proud of as a scientist. After Richie's original paper came out in 2004, a wave of research on mindfulness supported its benefits. But over the last few years, other researchers come out challenging many of the findings.
批评者认为正念的好处被过度炒作了。有太多不同种类的冥修，以至于说它普遍有益是简单化的。此外，批评者说，正念训练实际上会引起有害的副作用。换句话说，把冥修当作人类苦难的万灵药是一个错误。其中一些批判性研究已经发表。最近发表了一篇，确实引起了很大轰动。它发表在一个非常引人注目的期刊《科学进展》上，它显示，与许多炒作相反，基于正念的减压，这个为期两个月的训练计划，并不会导致大脑的结构性变化。
Critics have argued the benefits of mindfulness are overhyped. There are so many different kinds of meditation that it's simplistic to say that it's universally beneficial. Plus, critics say, mindfulness training can actually cause harmful side effects. In other words, it's a mistake to think of meditation as a one-size-fits-all solution to human misery. Some of those critical studies have been published. And the last one was published quite recently, and really made a big splash. It was in a very high profile journal, science advances, and what it showed is that contrary to a lot of hype, that mindfulness-based stress reduction, this two-month program of training, does not lead to structural changes in the brain.
批评人士认为，正念的好处被夸大了。冥想的种类繁多，简单地说它对所有人都有益是片面的。此外，批评者表示，正念训练实际上会带来有害的副作用。换句话说，认为冥想是解决人类痛苦的万灵药是错误的。其中一些批判性的研究已经发表。最近发表的一篇更是引起了轰动。它发表在备受瞩目的期刊《科学进展》上，研究显示，与许多炒作相反，基于正念的减压法（这种为期两个月的训练项目）并没有引起大脑结构的改变。
You know, there was a lot of media hype about how you can grow your prefrontal cortex by doing two months of meditation. Well, our findings show that that's just very unlikely to be true. unlikely to be true. I'm not afraid to publish that kind of work. It doesn't diminish my personal commitment to meditating. It just even encourages me more. Two months is not going to do it. Maybe you have to meditate longer than that. And so I view science as a community enterprise where the work, the findings are going to be adjudicated in the community. And so, you know, we use the most rigorous methods that we possibly can use. We're not afraid to publish non-findings.
你知道，当时有很多媒体炒作，说只要进行两个月的冥想就能增大你的前额叶皮层。好吧，我们的研究结果表明，这几乎不可能是真的。这不可能是真的。我不怕发表那样的研究。这并没有减弱我对冥想的个人承诺。反而更鼓励了我。两个月是远远不够的。也许你得冥想更长时间。因此，我认为科学是一项社区事业，其中的工作和研究结果将在社区中接受评判和裁决。所以，你知道，我们使用了所能采用的最严谨的方法。我们不怕发表“无显著发现”的成果。
And we encourage others to take our data, take our findings and see if they can replicate them. When we come back, I ask Richie how he has applied his scientific findings to his own life. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Ritchie Davidson has tried for decades to study the effects of mindfulness and meditation on the mind. He has run experiments, scanned the brains of countless volunteers, and tried to understand what is happening inside the heads of meditators
我们也鼓励其他人采用我们的数据和发现，看看他们能否进行重复验证。稍后回来，我将问里奇他是如何将自己的科学发现应用到生活中的。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家里奇·戴维森几十年来一直致力于研究正念和冥想对心灵的影响。他做过实验，扫描过无数志愿者的头脑，并试图理解冥想者头脑内部到底发生了什么
when they say that contemplative practices make them less stressed and more compassionate. But even as he has run studies and published scientific papers, Ritchie has practiced meditation himself, and he has found that it has changed away his own mind works. Take, for example, a fear that will be familiar to many people, the terror of public speaking. In 1992, I was scheduled to give this major scientific talk. And I used to have a lot of anxiety about public speaking.
当他们说静修练习能让他们减少压力、更具同理心时。但即使在进行研究和发表科学论文的同时，里奇自己也一直在练习冥想，他发现这改变了他自己心智的运作方式。以许多人都熟悉的一种恐惧为例——对公开演讲的恐惧。1992年，我原本预定要作一场重大的科学演讲。我过去对公开演讲有很大的焦虑。
One of the ways that I learned to mitigate my anxiety is to literally write out word for word my talk. And so that's what I did. And I was sitting in the audience waiting for my turn to be called up, sitting next to a very senior colleague who I had great respect for. So this guy, he didn't realize what I had done. But he said the worst thing someone can do is to get up there and read a talk.
我学会缓解焦虑的方法之一，就是把演讲稿逐字逐句地写下来。这就是我当时做的。我坐在观众席里等待被叫到名字，旁边坐着一位我非常尊敬的资深同事。这个人，他并不知道我做了什么。但他却说，一个人能做的最糟糕的事情，就是站上去照本宣科地念稿子。
It's just so boring when scientists do that. He didn't know that I had done exactly that. And I just sort of looked at him and turned white. And so I made the kind of outrageous and courageous, I think decision. Two seconds later, if someone gets up and introduces me and I'm you know starting to get up and as I got up I handed this guy David my talk and just got up there and delivered it spontaneously. It was the first time I had ever delivered a spontaneous talk like that and you, you know, I would say it was
科学家那样做实在是太无聊了。他不知道我做的正是那样的事。我当时看了他一眼，脸都吓白了。于是我做了一个既出格又勇敢的决定。两秒钟后，当有人介绍我出场、我正准备起身时，在我起身的瞬间，我把这份演讲稿递给这位叫大卫的同事，然后直接走上台去即兴演讲。那是我第一次做那样的即兴演讲，你可以说，
okay. It wasn't great, but it wasn't terrible. I'm wondering does meditation help put something like this when it comes to these kinds of anxieties? Does it help sort of soothe these anxieties? Is it making it easier? Do you meditate before you give a talk in public now? Yes, I do meditate for a brief period of time, typically, before I give important talks. That's the way I prepare for them. It's really helped me, I would say, a lot. I really used to get quite nervous giving public talks.
还过得去。算不上多好，但也绝不糟糕。我想知道，面对这类焦虑时，冥想能帮忙解决吗？它有助于平息这种焦虑吗？它能让事情变得更容易吗？你现在在公开演讲前会冥想吗？是的，在发表重要演讲之前，我通常会进行短时间的冥想。这就是我为演讲做准备的方式。可以说它对我帮助很大。我以前在公开演讲时真的会非常紧张。
And I don't have that experience anymore. And I know others very well who have had very similar experiences and different kinds of meditation has really given them tools to help them with this. Notice that the fear of public speaking, like many fears, is about your concerns about what will happen to you in the future. It's like the beep you hear that tells you you are going to experience pain 10 seconds in the future. Your anticipation of the pain is itself a source of pain.
而现在我不再有那种经历了。据我所知，其他经历过类似情况的人也发现，各种不同的冥想确实为他们提供了应对这种状况的工具。请注意，对公开演讲的恐惧，和许多恐惧一样，关乎你对未来会发生什么事的担忧。这就好比你听到一声哔哔声，它预示着你将在10秒后经历痛苦。你对痛苦的预期本身就是痛苦的来源。
You haven't bombed your speech, you're just afraid it might happen, and your anxiety makes it harder for you to do well. Richie has also found that meditation has helped him deal with the anger that marked his early adulthood and his experiences as a parent. When my son was a teenager, we lived through three very tumultuous years, and it was really difficult. And he really challenged us in all kinds of ways. He didn't want us to be his parents anymore at the age of like 15 and thought that he could just go out and go on the street and hang out with his friends and be liberated from our parental constraints.
你的演讲并没有砸锅，你只是害怕它可能会发生，而你的焦虑让你更难发挥好。里奇还发现，冥想帮助他处理了曾充斥他早年成年期以及作为父母经历的愤怒。当我的儿子是个青少年时，我们经历了非常动荡的三年，那段时期真的很艰难。他在各方面都对我们提出了挑战。大约15岁时，他不再希望我们做他的父母，以为自己可以离开家到街上去和朋友鬼混，从而从我们的管教中获得自由。
How did you react when he said that Richard? How do you react when your 15 year old says he doesn't want you to be his parent anymore? What was your reaction? It was very difficult. There was definitely some anger that was part of my response. And, you know, the anger in retrospect was extremely unhelpful. So we didn't really appreciate the kind of social and emotional consequences of this. But my wife is a physician by training. My daughter was extremely successful academically. I've had a successful academic career.
理查德，当他说这话时，你是怎么反应的？当一个15岁的孩子说他不再希望你当他的父母时，你作何反应？你的反应是什么？非常艰难。我的反应中确实包含了一些愤怒。而且，事后回想起来，那份愤怒是极其无益的。所以我们当时并没有真正意识到这会带来什么样的社交和情感后果。但我的妻子是科班出身的内科医师。我的女儿在学术上非常成功。我也有过成功的学术生涯。
And then my son sort of felt like he landed in a foreign family because school was challenging for him. And at one point in time, we really thought he would, this was a kid who's not gonna be able to go to college. And so, you know, really required completely changing our expectations. And, you know, these are areas where I feel like my meditation practice has made an enormous difference
然后我的儿子却感觉自己好像降生在一个异国家庭，因为学业对他来说很有挑战性。有一段时间，我们甚至真的觉得这孩子可能连大学都考不上。所以，你知道，这确实需要彻底改变我们的期望。并且，你知道，在这些领域里，我觉得我的冥想练习发挥了巨大的作用
over the years. And you know, has really changed that domain of my behavior. And once we started giving up all of our hopes and dreams and expectations and really had just one hope and dream, which was simply that he'd be happy, once we were able to get to that point, then everything started changing. But you mentioned something interesting a second ago, which is that the role that we have, the expectations that we have in some ways prevented you, perhaps from being the father that you might have wanted to be. But talk about that, because it seems to me that part of what you're talking about
多年来。并且，你知道，这确实改变了我行为的那一部分。一旦我们开始放弃所有的希望、梦想和期望，真正只留下一个希望和梦想——那就是希望他快乐，一旦我们能达到那个境界，一切就开始改变了。但你刚才提到了一件有趣的事，那就是我们所扮演的角色、我们所怀有的期望，在某种程度上也许阻止了你成为你想成为的父亲。谈谈这一点吧，因为在我看来，你所谈论的内容的一部分
with these contemplative practices is also about the role of ego and how the ego is after shaping our behavior. It feels like there's a connection there. Yeah, there definitely is. And, you know, I very much had the view, you know, I'm a successful academic and I'm going to have kids that are going to be very successful in this realm. And that was part of my, you know, my self-image. You know, I attributed to my practice that we were able to pretty quickly see that and see how destructive that could be and able to let that go. And once we did that, you know, we kind of allowed natural resilience
通过这些静修练习，其实也关乎自我（小我）的角色，以及自我如何塑造我们的行为。这里面似乎有着某种联系。是的，确实有。而且，你知道，我以前抱有很强的观点，我是个成功的学者，我的孩子也必定会在这个领域非常成功。这是我自我形象的一部分。我将练习归功于我们能够相当快地看清这一点，并看到它是多么具有破坏性，从而能够放手。一旦我们做到了这一点，我们便释放了自然而然的韧性
and growth to emerge. And then he went to college, he went to graduate school, he became a school psychologist, he's married with a 15-month-old no and a wonderful father. a teen month old now and a wonderful father. But, you know, there was a lot of work that went into that and on both his part and our part. You tell a story about time when the Dalai Lama came to visit the United States and one time you were, you were greeting the Dalai Lama and having one of your students present some work. Tell me that
与成长得以显现。后来他上了大学，读了研究生，成了一名学校心理学家，现在结婚了，还有一个15个月大的孩子，是个很棒的父亲。现在有一个15个月大的孩子，是个很棒的父亲。但是，你知道，这其中付出了大量的工作，无论是对他的部分还是对我们。你讲过一个故事，关于达赖喇嘛访问美国的一次经历，当时你正在迎接达赖喇嘛，并让你的一个学生展示一些研究成果。讲讲那个
story of what happened because it was it sounds like it was a meaningful moment for you in your life, Richie. Yeah that was a very powerful moment. So when the Dalai Lama used to travel to the United States, he asked us to convene these very small meetings where we would just have maybe 12 people in the room. We would brief him on scientific research on meditation. So one year it was decided that rather than having the old senior folks like myself give the presentations, we're going to have young people who are graduate students and postdocs give the presentations. And one of the individuals who selected happened to be my graduate student.
发生了什么的故事吧，因为听起来对你的人生而言是一个意义重大的时刻，里奇。是的，那是一个非常震撼的时刻。当时达赖喇嘛访问美国时，他要求我们召集一些非常小的会议，房间里可能只有12个人左右。我们向他简要汇报关于冥想的科学研究。所以有一年，大家决定不再由像我这样的资深老人来做报告，而是让作为研究生和博士后的年轻人来做。被选中的其中一个人恰好是我的研究生。
I was asked to simply serve in the role of a moderator. And I introduced each of these trainees. I said a little bit about who they were and set the context for the research that they were doing and then moderated the discussion after they presented. And the student of mine who was presenting was the last person her name is Helen Wang and she's done some wonderful research on compassion. So when it came time to introduce Helen,
我被要求仅仅担任主持人的角色。我介绍了每一位受训者，简要说明了他们的身份以及他们正在进行的研究的背景，然后在他们陈述后主持讨论。进行陈述的我的学生是最后一位，她的名字叫海伦·王（Helen Wang），她做了一些关于同情心的精彩研究。所以到了介绍海伦的时候，
I said, you know, this is Helen wing, she's my graduate student, she's worked in my lab, and then I said a few other things and my experience of what happened next was the Dalai Lama grabbed my arm was the Dalai Lama grabbed my arm and in a very stern way, almost harsh, he said, don't use my, just like that. As in my graduate student, my lab. Yeah. And he was clearly seeing something in me that he wanted to give me feedback on. And I was shocked. I mean, I was just, my world completely stopped. I was shaken by it.
我说，这是海伦·王，她是我的研究生，曾在我的实验室工作，接着我又说了一些别的话。而我所经历的接下来发生的事情是，达赖喇嘛抓住了我的胳膊，达赖喇嘛抓住了我的胳膊，并以一种非常严厉、几乎近乎粗暴的方式说：别用“我的”，就像那样。比如“我的研究生”、“我的实验室”。是的。他显然在我身上看到了某种他想要向我反馈的东西。我当时震惊了。我是说，我的整个世界都停止了。我被吓到了。
And to this day, I reflect on that all the time. And it was just this unbelievably powerful teaching for me about humility. You know, it's not really about me and my, it's, that's just my ego, my self grasping. You know, clearly the work of any student is the product of so many different causes and conditions to personally own it in this way was just so biased
直到今天，我仍然经常反思这件事。对我来说，这是一个难以置信、震撼人心的关于谦逊的教导。你知道，这其实并不真的关乎我和我的……那只是我的小我和自我执着。显然，任何学生的成果都是众多不同因果条件共同作用的产物，而以这种方式将之据为己有实在是太偏颇了
really and just narrow. I mean it speaks to what you were telling me at the start of the conversation which is really that there is a world that is out there but we process that world through our minds, and paying attention to how our minds are processing the world really changes the world that we experience. Exactly. I could not put it any better. Richard Davidson is a psychologist at the University of Wisconsin-Madison. He is the author of Altered Traits and the founder and director of the University Center for Healthy Mines. Richie, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
而且非常狭隘。这与你在谈话开始时所说的不谋而合，也就是确实存在着一个外部世界，但我们是通过自己的心灵去加工这个世界的，而关注我们的心灵是如何加工这个世界的，确实会改变我们所体验到的世界。完全正确。我再也找不到比这更好的表达了。理查德·戴维森是威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校的心理学家。他是《圮变的特质》（Altered Traits）一书的作者，也是威斯康星大学健康心智中心的创始人和主任。里奇，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you so much, Shankar. You're free. You're wonderful questions. I really appreciate it. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Hidden Brain listener
非常感谢你，尚卡尔。你太客气了。你的问题非常精彩。我真的很感激。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·帕尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们今天的无名英雄是《隐藏的大脑》的听众
and supporter Amy Galdner. She writes, my husband and I, both love, love, love the spot cast. We both geek out over neuroscience and find it so applicable to our personal and professional lives. If you also find Hidden Brain to be useful to you in your daily life, please consider joining Amy in supporting our work. You can do so by joining Hidden Brain Plus, a subscription program via Apple Podcasts. You can find it on the Apple Podcast tab or at apple.co slash Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和支持者艾米·高德纳。她写道：我和丈夫都非常非常喜欢这个播客。我们俩都对神经科学着迷，并发现它对我们的个人和职业生活非常适用。如果你也发现《隐藏的大脑》对你的日常生活有所帮助，请考虑加入艾米一起来支持我们的工作。你可以通过 Apple Podcasts 上的订阅项目 Hidden Brain Plus 加入我们。你可以在 Apple Podcasts 的标签页上找到它，或者访问 apple.co/Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。